simbólica estructura de la arquitectura
china se alza en mexicalli ciudad del
norte de méxico a miles de kilómetros
del país asiático el zinc señala el
inicio de la chin ska centenario barrio
chino a quien arturo villaseñor abre las
puertas y revela secretos de la magia
del barrio
cuál es su secreto
no están moviendo constantemente
[Música]
subiéndolo hivacat ole a la lumbre por
qué
al mismo
[Música]
pero más allá de la gastronomía las
decoraciones chinas y los callejones que
albergan sótanos bajo su superficie las
chinescas con de una historia de
migración
a finales del siglo 19 en medio de la
decadencia del imperio chino cientos de
barcos provenientes de cantón y hong
kong desembarcaron en las costas del
pacífico mexicano a bordo de ellos
inmigrantes chinos que buscaban mejores
oportunidades económicas en el pujante
eeuu muchos de ellos no pudieron cruzar
la frontera y se instalaron aquí en
mexicalli donde ahora se replican
algunas tradiciones de aquel pueblo
migrante
[Aplausos]
luego de años de abandono debido a la
falta de recursos económicos la chinesca
vuelve a ser de interés para las
autoridades locales y para empresarios
que ven la oportunidad de atraer a
turistas